Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
Monday,
May 14th,
2018 how are you?
What is going on with you?
Oh really?
Is that is,
that is interesting.
I just feel like for me,
do you know I went to a a for mother's Day,
by the way.
Happy Belated Mother's Day out there for all the women out there who love
others.
It,
you know,
there's nothing more important are loving it.
Gallery the way they go on and on about mothers.
Remember that on Father's Day?
Jesus Christ.
That's like a fucking blurb,
you know,
at the bottom of the stock exchange.
Oh,
by the way,
happy father's Day.
MMM.
There's nothing more important.
Hey.
Um,
anyways.
Anyways.
You know what I mean?
They're,
they're,
they're the quarterback.
They get all the fucking glory.
He is a father.
You're the left tackle,
you know,
protecting their ass and nobody gives a shit.
They don't even know when you get trade.
Nobody's sitting in the stands wearing your jersey.
Right.
Who the fuck buys a fucking left tackles fucking Goddamn Jersey.
MMM.
Is it the guard?
Is it the guard position?
Is that the one that's all important?
Is that though,
and I'm sure everybody who plays fantasy football and never competed in their
life will let me know that that's not exactly,
it's not to tackle,
it's the guard or is it to tackle?
I don't give a fuck.
MMM.
So we went to the,
uh,
the Getty villa,
which is a museum.
And uh,
evidently it's by this Guy John Paul Getty and John Paul Getty evidently was a
really rich guy and like a lot of rich guys.
Uh,
he didn't pay any taxes.
Evidently he went out,
he bought a bunch of art.
John Paul Getty,
let's see.
Didn't pay the taxes.
Let's see if this comes up with anything.
Uh,
the reason why J and j Paul Getty refuse to pay 16 or the billionaire refuse to
pay kidnappers.
All those kids kidnappers the tragedy of the Gettys on,
I feel bad.
What happened?
Severed ears.
Safari can open this page.
Is it still an active case?
Okay.
To a billionaire who refused to pay kidnappers to save as grandson's life?
What?
Oh man,
that would a cold bastard,
the upcoming film,
all the money in the world.
When the fuck did this come out.
Oh,
it's a film.
That doesn't mean anything that'd be do is based on a true story and then
everything else is going to be bullshit,
right?
It's like that movie hidden figures.
They start like taking real people and then they combine them together and they
amalgam like take three people and they combined them into one person and then
people start coming up to you.
When they start quoting movies like that,
like they read a fucking history book.
It's like,
no,
you went to the movies,
you ate gummy bears and popcorn.
That's not reading.
This is coming from someone who doesn't read.
Oh,
Kevin Spacey played fucking a fucking j Paul Getty,
the upcoming,
all the money in the world has been garnered and gardening a lots of buzz for
the scandal around it a month ago.
The filmmakers to Jesus Christ,
not that scan.
I want to hear about the fucking kids life.
All right.
But the scandal and propose based on a 1973 John Paul Getty,
the third,
the 16,
the 16 year old grandson of the oil men,
Jay Paul Getty then said to be the world's richest man,
where some 1.2 billion,
which is around 9.1 billion today,
was kidnapped in Rome,
is it?
Ductors demanded 17 million bucks with this guy probably had in his breast coat
pocket.
Although rich people never walk around with Dick,
you know,
they never have,
they never fucking have it.
Um,
which is family wouldn't pay leading to his captors to cut off his right ear.
The ordeal coupled with terrible neglect,
ruined the boy's life at just 24 he ended up paralyzed,
has as a result of a drug overdose.
As it turns out,
all the money in the world could not save him.
Okay.
Wow.
I wonder what he was probably thinking,
well,
if I pay this guy,
I'm going to have to pay everybody.
Okay.
I'm not given yet.
Shabbit Chade Melea and you realize how many Derrek Saca bye
yelling at his daughter.
Well,
fuck yeah.
Christ.
They're afraid.
That's one of the few things in life,
that story,
make it a baby.
Making a baby is free.
You know,
provided you can find a woman that doesn't need to go on a date and have a
relationship first.
Um,
other than that,
it's probably one of the more expensive thing she'd do.
Um,
how are you everybody?
This is the Monday morning podcast.
It's a little bit late.
Um,
cause I was out celebrating mother's Day.
I realized for the 9000000th time of my life,
I am not a museum guy.
Um,
unless it's like a museum of cars,
drums.
I would literally enjoy seeing a museum of refrigerators that started with ice
boxes,
you know,
and they just,
wow.
Racking on 18 fucking teams that first or ice cars bought icebox found her fate.
God's your fucking IC bark.
You love cops.
Get your rights here.
Right?
Watch one of those things.
I went to the Harley Davidson Museum.
I obviously enjoyed that,
you know,
but I'm not a headphones guy.
You know,
you get to the fucking museum.
I'm going to tell you guys what kind of Guy I am by telling you all the guys I'm
not,
and then you can do process of elimination.
Okay.
What you've learned on this fucking podcast already.
I'm at a museum guy.
I'm not a headphones guy and a few podcasts back.
I told you I was at breath breakfast guy.
All right.
I'm the kind of guy that tells you what kind of guy he is and he isn't whether
you asked or not.
And I'll go on and on and on and on and on and you won't even get to speak.
I just got a guy a am.
Um,
I don't like going to museums and you get that little fucking recorder and then
you have like the headphones and shit.
You got to walk around and look at every God damn exhibit.
I just kind of blow through it and get a gist.
And if anything catches my eye,
I'm fine with it.
You know,
I don't need to look at every God damn knickknack and see what like a broach
look like in the Middle Ages.
Um,
so I went to the j Paul Getty Phila
um,
and I imagine 17 million probably put that pool in,
so all then a lot of people would give their ear for that.
So maybe he was right.
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
Um,
okay.
That's what I would do if my parents were that fucking rich.
My parents were that God damn rich,
I would,
I would die of a drug overdose or something my to go out and get a job.
You know what sucks is when you're that level rich,
they can always hang it over your head.
Okay.
So I would probably rebelled and just go my own way.
Be One of those fucking morons,
you know?
Okay.
Stead of having a fucking chumps wherever you hoop,
all of a sudden you gotta take fencing classes and all that shit that makes you
a gentleman.
Um,
learn how to sail
in all that rich white shit that if you're in a fucking will,
you know what I mean?
First of all,
someone that has that,
that amount of money for the most part,
you know,
as far as the movies,
tell me when I sit to written,
you know,
I don't eat gummy bears.
I always go with the fucking peanut M and.
M's.
You can't get the ones that don't have peanuts in them.
When you get the plain m and,
m's,
if you actually eat a movie size bag of one of those,
you are so full of sugar.
Like you start having like disturbing thoughts.
You got to get the peanut M and.
M's.
I think oral,
get the chocolate covered,
covered almonds.
Hey,
I'm a fucking peanut m and M guy.
I'm not a plain Eminem.
What did I start saying?
What kind of Guy I am?
This is some middle aged shit.
You realize that when you start talking about that shit,
you know,
trying to carve out,
hoping somebody someday it's gonna make a statue of you.
It ain't happening.
Do you realize how many people you have to kill and oppressed in order to get a
statue made out of you?
You know,
if you don't have an athletic ability,
but even then you got to crush a lot of homers dunk.
A lot of balls score,
a lot of goals throw for a bunch of touchdowns is you've got to do a lot of shit
to get a statue.
Everything's lot.
So if you're in power,
you have to press a lot of people,
you have to kill a lot of people,
you know,
or maybe died tragically.
It's not worth it.
You know what I mean?
Even if feel like fucking one of those athletes that gets,
gets a statute because then what happens,
you know,
you miss your kids growing up while you were out there and fucking,
getting you Gordie Howe had tricks.
What were the,
what were they doing it?
Huh?
There you were out there getting kidnapped,
getting there.
He has chopped off.
So,
you know,
I guess,
I guess what I'm trying to say,
is this a price that everybody pays?
Um,
yeah.
So I went to that museum and um,
the only thing I liked,
they had giant ball of playdough.
Then for some reason took somebody 20 years to put together
an,
I can't imagine how much still their significant other much the complaint.
You know,
I was a guy,
I don't know if my wife just started doing that with the play dough after a
while I go guy.
I like it keeps her happy.
Yeah.
I was going to say she's out of my hair,
but I don't have any.
Um,
other than that,
I don't know.
It's just a bunch of fucking weird looking statutes.
Nobody looked happy back in the day.
You know,
everybody's just fucking grumpy as,
because most people died by the time they were like 20,
like,
yeah.
You're like now like people have a problem contemplating their own mortality
cause you can,
you know,
even if you're a moron,
you,
you can pretty much live a good 70 years so you don't have to think about it for
awhile.
You can stand there on your smart phone.
Right.
Did you take a picture of the menu and then text,
what should I get to your fucking boyfriend and your girlfriend?
Whatever your deal is,
but deck.
Then you know,
people like,
he got a fever and you just died.
You know,
you fell off something,
you know,
your leg turned fucking black.
He just teaches,
fucking people died back then.
You know,
they didn't just keep going the way we do.
Once you fucking,
you know,
if anything happened to you back then,
you've just fucking died.
Mothers given birth,
died,
babies died two for one right there.
You know,
it really is amazing.
You got to,
you can really have to appreciate the level of fucking that has been done
globally for us to get to this level.
I guess maybe it's science,
you know,
coming up with aspirin and shit like that.
Um,
you know,
this is even dumped for me.
I'm really stepping outside of myself.
Listen to this.
Here's a funny story for you.
Real quickie.
All right.
Last night I went down to the comedy store.
They had the memorial ceremony for a Mitzi shore.
Uh,
the woman who created,
started the,
uh,
the comedy store and ran it for decades.
And basically because of what she did,
I got to see all of these comedians that I watched that um,
yeah,
made me want to be a comedian was because that she started the place and looked
out for him and all of that stuff.
So I had to go down there,
you know,
even though I only met her twice,
one time I didn't really even meet her.
I was auditioning for and they will like to submit,
she show and she barely looked at me and I went up on stage and I don't even
know how much time I did,
but she was gone by the time I got off.
And her,
um,
review was a,
he has in ready,
yes.
[inaudible] me off.
She was right.
I wasn't ready.
Um,
and then years later I got in.
Okay.
And I talked to her briefly,
so,
you know,
I didn't want to go up.
Okay.
You know,
I hate when people go up on a memorial service and talk when they didn't fucking
know the person.
So,
uh,
unfortunately I didn't get to know her.
Um,
but I definitely more than profited off of all the work that she did and all the
comics before,
so thank you to all of them.
So anyway,
so I'm down there and,
uh,
okay.
You don't get to watch all these people talk and tell him these hilarious
stories about Mitzi and the comedy store back in the day.
And a,
this person comes up to me
and goes,
hey,
you know,
I guess like an audience member or something was,
I was at,
you know,
comedy groupie assumption was gone.
A,
I was in fucking,
uh,
I was at your show the other night.
Well,
you tried out a bunch of new stuff.
I said,
I,
you know,
a few things here or there when new,
but you know,
for the most part,
you know,
it's the proven stuff.
And she goes,
what about that me to stuff?
And I said,
uh,
I know I've had that sense,
you know,
shit started going down and she goes,
would you like to hear my opinions of that material as a woman,
as a female?
She goes,
would you like to hear my opinions on that material as a female?
And I just go,
no.
Yeah,
I walked away.
I just love that.
Would you like to hear my opinions as a female?
What does that mean?
As a female,
you are a female.
Could you give me your opinions as a Hermaphrodite?
Do you know,
how would you do that?
Um,
I have no idea.
I don't,
I,
and I,
I'm just,
I'm sure that person is a nice person.
I didn't take offense to it,
but it was one of the easiest questions I've ever had to answer.
And I just walked away.
And to her credit,
she laughed and I just walked away.
But,
um,
I think that's just a symptom of,
you know,
just the Internet.
Now you can comment on fucking youtube videos.
You can comment on fucking,
uh,
you know,
fucking spew every thought.
You have a fucking Abbott on podcasts.
I'm literally talking to myself,
so maybe that's what the fuck it is.
But I've never in my life,
I've never had a conversation like that was fucking bizarre.
Oh yeah.
By all means.
Why don't you,
you punch up my shit.
That's what I was waiting for.
A complete stranger to help me out with my act.
Could I have a complete strangers set of eyes on this shit?
And by the way,
the material,
I did it fucking killed it.
Fucking killed that night.
Let me get your opinion as you didn't like it.
Oh,
maybe that's why I'm doing it.
Okay.
Do you have a notice?
Some kind of an asshole?
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
Did anybody watched the f one race over there and fucking a in Spain place?
I would love to go someday.
MMM.
What an exciting race.
They got to do something,
man.
They got to do something to these cars where there's some sort of passing in the
front row.
It's like Lewis Hamilton just fucking,
he just,
he just got to the corner first he was in pole position and then that,
that was it.
The one exciting thing was Ferrari pit it early and they went to the medium
tires,
you know,
I remember that.
The one,
the ones with the white lettering,
I'm medium.
It's cause they always say white guys are boring,
average,
whatever,
you know,
that's how I remember those.
And then I always forget like yellow soft,
it's super soft.
It's a pink right.
And I'm not going to get to the metaphor about debt,
but anyways,
um,
the only exciting thing was when,
uh,
Sebastian Vettel pitted early and changed his tires and it was just like,
is he going to be able to catch them in that?
And that was answered pretty fucking quickly with a resounding no.
And I'm somehow Lewis Hamilton absents such a shitty fucking start is fucking a,
he's back in first place again.
And I don't know why it bugs me.
Okay.
That was just because years ago I remember when like,
you know,
he was asking his teammate to fucking help him out.
This is when he had the,
uh,
the,
the fucking days of thunder,
Ricky Bobby Shit going on with that fucking guy.
What the fuck was his name back in the take?
Nico Rosberg they didn't get along.
Okay.
So Nico was being a teammate for him,
a few races earlier.
And then when it was flipped and Nico was winning the race and they needed Lewis
Hamilton to do something,
you know,
basically do the same thing that Nico did for him.
He fucking refuse,
which is not what you're supposed to do.
You know,
he went Koby Bryant on it.
I want the ball.
Um,
and ever since then I was like,
ah,
fuck it.
Fuck this guy.
I don't like this guy with this red private jet.
All right.
I'm stalking them.
I don't like literally not like the guy,
but that was just one of those things.
It's just like,
okay.
You know,
I don't know.
Um,
so anyways,
so I have somehow being German and Irish guy,
I should be rooting for the fucking Mercedes team.
Right.
I'm mostly chairman.
MMM.
But,
uh,
for some reason I'm rooting for Ferrari.
Maybe cause it's just every time,
every fucking year.
It's like Mercedes wins the two years that I've been watching it.
I think that's,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
Louis,
would you like to hear my opinions of your driving as a male who doesn't drive
competitively?
Um,
so anyways,
I'm up here in San Francisco.
That's why I had an early flight today and that's why the podcast is a very late
today.
Um,
slow up here.
It was funny.
I check the weather in San Francisco and right before the window opened I said
gloomy and shitty and that's exactly what it is.
Although the sun's coming out right now.
This,
this,
everybody talks about Seattle,
how it rains and his fucking gloomy and all that to,
I don't know,
I have had more sunny days on shows in fucking Seattle
in Portland combined than I have the,
every time I've come here it's just always just sort of a,
you know,
you always have to have a jacket.
I can't like if I ever started a store here in San Francisco,
I wouldn't try to fuck with the burritos cause everybody's got that locked down.
But I would definitely have some sort of jacket and hat store.
It's just fucking miserable here.
And I'm staying at this hotel.
I'm doing one show a night,
7:00 PM shows.
I love it.
I'm an old guy.
I love the 7:00 PM one show done at nine o'clock.
I come home,
I get in the bed,
I fucking relax.
You know,
I do my resent a stone,
a little bit of French,
you know,
not hurting anybody,
just an old bald white guy.
Right.
Um,
but anyways,
you know,
I wanted to do my big birthdays coming up 50 turning 50 June 10th Beck's fucking
months.
So I wanted to uh,
drop the last couple of pounds and I went downstairs and they got this Shitty
fucking gym.
It's the worst.
Do you have a chance?
Yeah,
we have the chip now.
He had,
don't did JIM is smaller than my Roman.
I have a basic fucking room with two queen beds that,
Oh,
maybe the gym is the same.
So I think they just took a Roman,
they just,
they got,
they got one,
that thing where you sit down and pretend you're riding a bicycle,
which nobody gets on that.
Right.
Uh,
people who wear makeup and read US magazine while they work out,
get on that fucking thing.
Then they got an elliptical great.
But they only got one and right next to it is a treadmill and right next to that
as a treadmill.
And then you're at the wall.
They got a couple of kettle bells.
They've got some dumbbells,
they got no bench,
you know,
so I guess you just deal with shoulders and curls.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know what.
And uh,
they got a couple of dirty bands down there.
Those elastic pants.
Well fortunately I brought some shit with me,
but um,
I dunno,
I could start making demands here.
If I'm going to be in a hotel,
the gym has to be bigger than my hotel room.
Can there be more than one?
Cause you know what's going to happen.
Yeah,
you're going to go down there and it's just to be fucking,
you know,
you get down there in the morning,
it's just going to be those gym rats down there just fucking all over those
things.
Sweating and shit.
It's going to be gross.
But fortunately it's San Francisco,
so I'm just going to walk the hills.
I think that's what I'll do.
Um Oh and how bout those Celtics?
I taped the game,
I didn't see one second of it.
I was over at the j Paul Getty Pavilion,
whatever the fuck I was the um,
the villa,
which uh,
I you actually,
when I fly,
well I do solo flights.
I fly out of Burbank a lot and I go all the way out past a Camarillo.
I always call Kamma Rio cause it rich came a real punch up for the Patriots and
then it come down the coast all the way down Malibu raise,
you get to the Pacific Palisades,
she get on with the Santa Monica airport and you see at the,
at the Getty villa,
Pella Copter,
whatever,
whatever.
I'm Santa Monica Tower,
helicopter,
whatever,
uh,
south bottle on the coast at the uh,
Getty villa questing fucking eastbound transition.
So your fucking airspace.
Um,
sorry,
I'm out of it.
This is why I never do podcasts when I fly.
I don't know what the hell happens.
Um,
I flew southwest and there was no fucking stand up on the flight.
It was great.
No bad stand up on the flight
and a cruise right up here.
Great flight.
And all that.
And um,
I,
anyway,
so yesterday I was at the fucking,
the Getty a filler and a that's when the Celtics game was on.
I missed the whole fucking game.
And uh,
I don't know how we did it but we beat them and we won by 20 points,
which is amazing.
But I'm thinking that might have been like a fucking hangover game because uh,
no.
Yeah they will do what they were idle.
That's right.
Cause they swept a Toronto.
So game too is fucking huge.
Game Two,
I actually think if we win game two,
having watched three Celtics games this year,
if we win game two,
we,
I think actually I think game two is a must win.
MMM.
Because uh,
okay
cause they got Lebron James,
Lebron James,
one of the biggest enigmas I've ever,
as far as like what that guy is done versus the level of shit that he gets.
I just,
I don't understand it.
Yeah.
Is,
are people ever going to fib,
forgive that guy for taking his talents down to south beach.
All right.
So he went down there.
He was part of a couple of pile on fucking teams,
but then he went back to Cleveland at one,
them their first fucking championships since fucking Jim Brown in 1965.
That should have been the end of the movie.
The man redeem himself that I've never seen a guy,
no matter what the fuck he does,
people find a reason to shit over.
Um,
and what kills me is meanwhile Coby Bryant demanded free agents every fucking
year for shack out of town,
cost them a fucking championship.
Cause Shaq was still in his prime.
He went to Miami,
they went there.
Um,
never gets any shit.
Yeah.
Or doesn't get nearly as much shit.
I don't,
I,
for the life of me,
I don't understand why Lebron James get so much shit.
Um,
he's literally willingness team into the,
into the conference finals.
Um,
so whatever other people don't understand that guy.
I get,
I get who that fucking dude is.
And a,
I think if we don't win game two,
we have no shot at went in this series.
And even if we do win game two,
because of Lebron James,
um,
I dunno,
I got 200 bucks on this series stuff.
Somebody talked me into it.
I was like,
dude,
I ain't got a fucking bag.
If we went to games,
I want to be thrilled.
We got to the Eastern Conference finals,
you know,
without Rick Robbie and Eric Bernstein,
who's that guy that we got from the Cavaliers who's up?
I already don't remember his name.
The other guy that Mel Howard that we got from fucking Utah.
I missed every Celtic game this year.
Just about,
except for like maybe two.
Um,
I know Jaylen Brown and a rosier and Tatum have been the story a Kyrie Irving.
There we go.
MMM.
I think next year we're going to look pretty good.
Be Great to get another championship before the Lakers rebuild.
Uh,
I dunno.
We'll see.
We'll see what the fuck happens.
But I should probably,
you know what's great though is the fact that I have early shows,
I think I can actually,
uh,
catch a lot of the games this week.
Maybe get back into its fucking lyrics and watching the Celtics for the last two
years and now they're like,
[inaudible],
well,
I can't say a legit shot to be killed.
You know that I didn't know what the fuck I'm talking about this week.
Why don't I just do a little bit of a advertising here?
How about that?
I went old school,
by the way,
I brought all my shit up here,
but all my podcasts and stuff up here is something I haven't done in a while and
he would think if I were to bring all my equipment up here,
I'd actually have a decent podcasts,
but I haven't.
Alright.
Simply stay for everybody.
It's important to protect your home with a home security system.
How can we protect your home and your privacy?
That's what I love about simply safe.
They obsess over details like no other home security company.
Here's an example.
Simply save as a camera.
You can control from your phone.
You know what I,
in the future,
they're going to have something that tells you if somebody's coming up,
your walk is a person or a robot.
Okay?
That's what I'm guessing.
But they want to protect your home and your privacy.
So they came up with this brilliant idea,
a privacy shutter for the camera.
Now simply safe.
What?
I don't even know what just happened there.
An example,
it simply safe,
has a camera you control,
can control from your phone,
but they want to protect your home and your privacy.
So they came up with this brilliant idea,
a privacy shutter for the camera.
I don't understand how,
what,
what is your face looking out of the camera and the and the guy breaking in
concede or are you worried about somebody on the bus looking over your shoulder
and seeing where you live going?
Oh,
I know I recognize that shrub.
I don't get,
what do I don't know when it's going on right now.
Now simply safe wanted you to be able to hear the shutter.
Click.
See,
you know it's closed.
They wanted to have it.
Have a light on it so you could easily tell when it's on.
And they needed it to work for the entire lifespan of the system.
So simply safe.
Got To work.
Testing different metals and hinge designs for months and months.
The result in effective home security camera with a thin,
lightweight aluminum privacy shutter
that will work every time.
I don't understand what they're protecting your phone.
What's the privacy?
Is that kind of attention to detail that said simply safe apart and keeps your
family safe?
I don't know what they did,
but it seems like they work real hard on it.
Simply safe isn't just a home security.
It's home security.
Done right.
Checkout simply safe.
Today's,
that's simply safe dot.
No,
simply say bird.com it's simply [inaudible] dot com to learn more about simply
safe today.
Hi.
Simply safe bird.com I could read that a thousand times and I wouldn't
understand what the fuck that is.
All right.
Ah,
toto toto me.
Andy's Biondi going to a fucking museum,
dude.
Dude.
Dude,
dude.
Mizani needs beyond Z.
Elise is not a Mazda.
Liam.
Sorry.
Needed to run.
Look at all the old shit.
Isn't it nice?
Go out to the cafeteria and order some rice.
It tastes like shit in it's 100 bucks cause you're eating at a fucking museum
with a bunch of snotty kids.
Um,
I don't like little boys by the way.
Now that I have a daughter,
if they're always fucking jumping around,
making all kinds of noise and fucking bumping into kids,
I really don't like him.
The amount of times I've fantasized about punting one of those little bastards
across the fucking room.
You know,
I had my daughter there at the museum and I just knew these fucking kids,
you know,
and they neither doing dumb shit little boys do to try to get attention,
talking in weird voices and jump around flailing their fucking arms.
Good Lord.
As much as I can't stand my eyes and I realized that I was one of them.
Alright me undies,
you've definitely heard me talk about me undies.
You know the fun,
comfy undies that feel just as good as they look to those.
You haven't tried them yet.
Listen Up.
You can get incredible underwear.
It's shipped to your door with me undies meaning,
uh,
no more hunting around for the perfect pair at a crowded store.
And eventually settling for good enough.
This is how spoiled we are as human beings smell going out and buying underwear
is considered to be a form of hunting.
Me undies is so sure you'll love your first pair,
that if you're not happy,
they'll do whatever they can to get you went to the right pair.
And if they can't keep them and they'll refund you.
So it's really so it really is risk-free to try the best underwear ever.
And if you're already part of the me undies family,
tell your friends about it through their referral program.
They'll get a discount and you'll get store credit.
It's a win win.
Still not sure.
Well me,
Andy's has a deal from my listeners.
First Time purchasers get 20% off their first pair of undies and free shipping
as 20% off,
plus free shipping,
and a guarantee that you and your [inaudible] will be very happy together.
Uh,
get your butt over to me undies.com and treat yourself to get you 20% off your
first pair of free shipping on a percent satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] that's [inaudible] dot com slash
bar.
All right,
next $1 shave club to Joe.
Did you see a bar stool?
Sports fucking retweeted that clip.
When that guy from the Celtics Lakers 30 for 30.
Why the Celtics going to win?
Because they are because they shall take said Paul,
he's fucking high pitched voice.
Uh,
if you ever shower a brush your teeth or try to make your hair look presentable.
All right,
200 300 bed.
Here's some good news.
Dollar Shave Club has a low a lot of stuff to help you out.
Dollar Shave Club.
Yes.
That dollar shave club delivers everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
You name it.
Shampoo,
conditioner,
body wash,
toothpaste,
Hair Gel.
Even a wipe that will leave you at twitch.
Feeling Tingley clean.
You'll be a big fan of their amber and lavender calming body cleanser.
It doesn't that sound wonderful after you try it for the first time.
Good luck finding a product that,
that great at the store.
Well,
I'm sure you could,
isn't it?
We were selling the convenience of it though.
It's not fucking overstep our bounds here.
Dollar Shave Club,
like he can't find that a story.
You can find that.
Um,
anyways,
but you,
who the fuck wants to go out there?
You're already getting your underwear delivered to you when I have all the other
shit that she used before you put on your underwear's.
All of dollar shave club's products are made with top shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget.
You feel the difference.
Plus shipping is free with your membership in is a great way to try a bunch of
dollar shave club's products for just five bucks.
You can get their daily essential static kit.
It comes with body cleanser,
one wipe Chai,
we,
they're amazing but wipes.
They're world famous shave butter and their best razor.
It's six.
I wish I had some of those one wipe Charlies.
Now this fucking hotel has that tear your ass up.
Toilet paper.
You know,
you let shit that so much.
See through you got to do is like half the fucking roll so you can't see your
hand on the other side of it.
Um,
and their best raises his six blade executive razor.
Keep the blades coming for a few more bucks a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste or anything else you need.
Speaking of your next month for a limited time,
only use the code [inaudible] at checkout to get $5 off your second month of the
club.
That's code burpee you are are@dollarshaveclub.com to save $5 on your second
month.
Join the club today,
today,
today and lastly,
but certainly not leastly.
These are not in order of popularity.
I just read them as they come headlining.
Once again,
stamps.com everybody use post used.
Use the US Postal Service is an important tool for any business by and print
official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide out of the fucking blue,
the best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com I'm going to be using it when I send out my,
uh,
my posters over to Dublin and London,
England.
I'm a more on if I can figure it out.
So can use use.
So can you high right now?
You too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the [inaudible] top of the homepage and type in Burr.
That's stamps.com enter burr day.
You Go,
ah,
yeah.
Speaking of which,
this run a dates here is my last two now before I go over there and do these,
those two huge shows,
which I'm in a good way,
I am nervous about.
Okay.
I want to make sure that I have a good show.
So I am going to be doing a bunch of shit this week and then that'll be what the
end of this week will be the 18th
okay.
All right.
Sounds.
So I still have a have like a two week gap.
I'm going to have to do a lot of fucking popping in,
doing some shows to make sure I stay on my fucking game here.
Um,
all right.
In the eye of the beholder.
Oh fuck.
Why didn't I write that down?
Oh,
you know what,
cause since my Bruins lost in the playoffs,
um,
I ended up,
uh,
some friends wanting to get together and they wanted to play that Metallica,
Metallica song,
eye of the beholder from the off of the injustice for all album.
I believe it's track number two.
And um,
so I've been listening to all this Metallica and uh,
I never used to listen to them.
Okay.
I went the other way.
I listened to more fucking,
uh,
warrant.
Then I listened to Metallica.
I like single bass drum plane and I just like,
it was just too raw,
too fast for my years.
I never get into it.
So now of course I'm going back down plus to have going,
oh my God,
this shit is unbelievable.
And um,
I actually sat down,
I took a video of,
I'll take a video of it and I'll,
I'll post it.
I actually wrote the entire drum chart out in my own chicken scratch.
I didn't put down the high ed or Monday may the crash symbols,
just uh,
just so I could make sense of this song.
And what I noticed about Lara's playing is he's pretty,
uh,
religious when it in the chorus and then,
you know,
a lot of time changes obviously on that album.
So those drum parts are pretty repetitive,
but in the fucking versus that guy is just like flying by the seat of his pants.
So he has all these different little things that he does and um,
yeah,
really,
really fun album to listen to.
And so I sat down and I wrote out the whole fucking drum chart for that song.
It's like four or five pages long because I was trying to memorize it.
I'm like,
this is going to take me for fucking ever.
Why do I know how to read drum music?
So why don't I just sit down and write this shit out and I'm,
I'm really glad that I did,
but then I have to watch out,
like,
like I get into shit.
So then all of a sudden it's like,
well,
I'm going to write up the drum shot for shortest Straw.
I'm going to do the whole fucking album.
Um,
anything to keep me out of the bath.
I'm not going to lie to you.
I had one drink Saturday and one drink Sunday,
small ones and uh,
yeah,
very small.
It's,
and now I'm back on the wagon again.
So,
uh,
that's how I'd like to drink.
I,
I'd like to really think about drinking now before I do it,
which is what I think about is the next morning and how awesome I have felt not
drinking.
So,
uh,
I had a very,
very,
very fucking incredible Tequila and,
uh,
it wasn't even a finger,
like as far as how much I poured,
maybe it was a finger.
Um,
and I just sip it.
It was nice.
I really enjoyed it.
Didn't even have ice on it.
Not that,
just really nice.
And then that was it.
And then I was done.
And then I had a water right next to it and I go at one,
if I go to the water that that fucking makes me not go like,
oh,
I'm going to have a fucking bunch of these.
Um,
so anyways,
I think I'm going to,
uh,
the goal anyways.
It's just kind of chill this week.
And,
um,
you know,
I've been talking to a couple of my buddies who've just been starting to slow
down a little bit with the drink it and it's just more like,
I don't know how you look at it,
you know,
cause I not by any means a young man anymore and that shit will fucking age you
and kick the shit out of you.
And,
uh,
life is hard enough.
I don't need to be adding that,
you know.
So anyways,
speaking of which,
I found a healthy place to my hotel and I just walked down there,
got that stuff and all that Shit,
you know?
So I guess I got it.
I got it.
It's time to pass the baton.
Okay.
Partying is a young man's fucking game and,
uh,
I'm done with it
there.
I said it,
I want to be done with it.
I should say every once in a while though,
every once in a while,
you know,
I go to that one big college football game a year.
I go to the Rose Bowl and uh,
you know,
whatever.
Maybe three,
four times a year.
But other than that,
I,
I'm fucking done with this shit.
I'm okay.
I hope anyways.
All right.
Ex Wife pretended to be my parole officer.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
a Billy blue balls.
I wish making this story.
I wish I was making this story up,
but I am not.
Well,
how would she pretend to be your parole officer without you knowing she must
have done it to somebody else somehow.
She must've fucked you over.
Anyways,
I'm in my early forties and had been married for 12 years.
Unfortunately,
the marriage ended in a divorce last year,
but when she found out you were in the mob,
I have fought.
You're married for 12 years.
It's guys like a responsible fucking dude.
He ends up going to jail even though we had no children.
My wife got to keep the house in the divorce settlement.
Of course she did.
But they're always victims.
And the guys always the fucking asshole.
Um,
divorces and alimony are expensive.
So for the past year I had been renting a townhouse.
Well Dude,
you're doing fine.
You renting a townhouse and this little community,
uh,
where most of the other residents are elderly couples.
Oh,
I see.
See,
waiting for someone to die and you moved in there.
I love it.
Uh,
I enjoy like just don't steal their fucking social security checks.
I enjoy living here and even though most of the other residents are older,
there is a nice community center that has a tennis court.
Yeah.
You fucking beaten everybody feeling like a young man and a pool and events
during the week and sometimes even live music.
So all in all,
not too bad of a situation.
Well about three months ago I met this great lady and we began to date,
my ex wife found out and did not take it well that I was back in the dating pool
so quickly.
Yeah.
Cause why getting the how,
you know,
she just got the fucking house.
So she went around to all my neighbors pretending to be my parole officer.
Wow.
Well,
they're all witnesses.
When are you sewer for defamation of character?
She can you do that?
She claimed that I am a registered sex offender and she was following up to see
if I had gone around door to door to admit to my neighbor I was a sex.
Oh,
you gotta sue the shit out of this woman.
Obviously I did not do this because I am not a sex offender and so all the
neighbors said no,
I not disclose to them my sex offender pass.
I had no idea my ex did this until a week later I got a letter from the
community board residence requesting that I move out for being in breach of
state laws require me to disclose my sex offenses.
All right,
dude,
all you need is a lawyer,
brother.
All you need is a lawyer.
This is easy.
This is fucking easy.
I,
of course went to the board and told them that they were all lies,
but they did not believe me because I could not prove I'm not a sex offender.
Yeah,
you can go get your fucking record.
I found a website and search my name and of course nothing came up,
but they wouldn't believe me.
Plus the dude,
this is so simple.
This is so simple.
So your wife and so this fucking say you're going to sue this old fucking folks
home if they kick you out.
Plus say said even I was telling,
even if I was telling you the truth and then my ex is lying,
they don't want me in my community because I hang around with people who
wouldn't lie about such a transgression.
Okay,
well that's,
that's kind of fair on their part.
I did not want to move,
especially because they said they did not,
they don't have to give me any sort of refund and I'd be liable to pay the
remainder of my lease.
I'm not sure what my options are and to involve the legal team will only add to
expenses.
Well,
you'll send them right back to her and I still may have to move.
What do I do?
Thanks for listening and go fuck yourself.
Well,
provided you're not a sex offender.
I would get a fucking lawyer and tell the guy,
listen,
you got to fucking,
you know what do they call that working pro bono or some shit working to the sag
minimum.
I would absolutely get a lawyer.
And I think you're the,
the,
the judge and your divorce case who handles your alimony and all that shit
should know what this woman did.
I would press,
I would find out whatever.
Um,
yeah,
whatever.
Legally you can do whatever a law she must get.
Can't be fucking legal to do that.
And then you got all that shit the day.
Do all the emotional stress and how this fucking effected you.
And I would sue the fucking shit out of her.
Um,
that is all,
that's what I would do.
Absolutely.
Get a lawyer.
Apps of Fucking Luli get a Lord Jesus fucking Christ.
Did you see this?
This is why this me too.
Shit.
Or you've created this thing now where you don't need any proof.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm all forgetting all these bad guys,
you know,
outdated and all that shit.
But you can't just create a system where you take due process and you throw it
out the fucking window.
Okay?
Because of shit like this,
and I know all the hype out there right now is that women are victims and there
are all these fucking angels.
And the truth of the matter is,
is there's assholes in this vindictive people out there who have dicks and
sometimes have vaginas and you can,
you just can't have people going around fucking doing stuff like this.
And you know,
if we're really going to go into a future where everything is fair,
you have to start,
you know,
women have to be responsible for their actions.
You can't fucking go around and do something like that over some petty bullshit
to fucking ruin a guy's life like that.
I mean,
do you realize like how vindictive that is?
That is unfucking believable.
And I like,
I be honest with you,
I would never in a million years matter how long I sat there and thought,
okay,
I could never come up with something as bad as that.
And,
um,
yeah,
I don't need to tell the guys listening to this step.
Women can effortlessly do that.
Hell hath no fury like a fucking woman scorned,
especially when they're not held fuck a response.
You know,
I just love how women can get away with like destruction of property.
There's even a commercial on TV where this guy's going through some sort of
breakup and this woman has just throwing all of his shit out the fucking window,
computers and all that,
and it's played for comedy.
It's fucking considered hilarious.
You know what I mean?
Which is fine.
I can roll with that.
But you can't,
uh,
you know,
have some overbearing guy screaming at his fucking wife played for comedy
anymore.
I guess she used to be able to do that.
But um,
you know,
sorry if you were actually innocent of all everything that she just did there,
I would absolutely.
You know what to,
why don't you start a startup?
Okay.
Started a startup to get a fucking lawyer.
You give me the link dude,
and I'll,
I'll throw 500 bucks at it.
Sue the shit out of her.
If she fucking did this to a sue,
the fucking shit out of it.
Good luck to you.
All right?
And I'll tweet out the fucking Lincoln.
Everybody just get on this thing and he,
let's get this guy a fucking lawyer so he can get on with his goddamn life.
He's not doing anything wrong according to him,
okay?
As long as what he's doing is telling the truth.
Other than that,
I think I might be given $500 to a sex offender.
Kidding.
All right.
Crazy wife.
Jesus,
they ladies,
can you guys write into,
cause I want to keep this balance.
I don't want it to this to be a fucking sausage fest here.
All right?
Um,
all right.
Crazy wife.
I have a wife.
I met overseas.
All right,
well,
you know what?
That's your fucking fault.
All right?
You know you're going to go over there and they're going to have their fucking
wooden shoes and they're awful teeth.
I mean what,
you know you're going to be over here and bring her around the buffalo wild
wings.
What do we think's going to happen anyways?
He goes on 25 and she's 22.
We're not technically married since we didn't finalize the paperwork.
Okay then what is the problem?
We just had the ceremony,
which is the only reason this question is worth asking.
Otherwise I just deal with it.
Okay,
fair enough.
By now it seems like the possibility of dealing with the consequences of
dropping her is the better option.
A.
Okay.
This is already sales.
Like you've already made your decision.
You just want me to back it up.
Uh,
we were dating two years.
She was normal,
but since we got married she flips out,
gets hysterical over little things to the point where I feel awkward to just be
next to her even when we're alone.
My first guest is,
uh,
she got married too young and she's freaking out.
Cause I would guess most of her friends aren't married yet at 22,
I think she must be bipolar or something.
She's still overseas.
I'm about to submit to the paperwork to get her a visa.
But I'm at a critical point in my future career that's very competitive and I
can't deal with any of that much less put up with it for the rest of our lives.
When she freaks out,
she says things like,
she wished she hadn't married me and fuck me and all that,
which is one thing.
But then she says she wishes she were dead and that she wants to kill herself.
Oh Dude,
dude.
You know what,
I would take that paperwork and I would go down to staples and say,
hey,
you know,
I'm in the market for a paper shredder.
Um,
do you have the cross cutting one?
And they'd be yes.
Any way you could plug it in.
I could just try it out.
And then when they plug it in,
you put that marriage contract and there to here.
Yeah.
Why?
And then look at the staples guy and be like,
yeah,
I mean it's nice,
but I don't,
I don't think I need it.
I don't think I like it.
And then just walk out.
All right,
because dude,
I think you're going to end up like the guy in the last one living in an old
folks home with some crazy fucking woman.
Anyways,
he goes,
I can find someone else by my friends and family.
No,
we got married and we're expecting to have her over soon.
Do your parents aren't going to give a fuck?
Is it better to bite the bullet and admit I made a dumb choice rushing into
marrying this girl before I have to deal with the divorce settlements and
absolutely is.
Keep in mind her culture is very old fashioned and our friends and family would
look down on her and she might never date slash marry again.
Not your problem,
not your fucking problem.
She met one foreigner,
she can meet another and in case you're wondering,
I'm an average looking white dude.
She's a solid eight to,
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
Okay,
dude,
I'll,
this is an in the fact that she's not even there.
I mean,
whatever the fuck you are,
this is,
this is the greatest thing ever.
The situation that you're in is so easy.
Just don't sign the papers,
you know,
just call and just be totally honest with just say your mood swings are so crazy
that I,
uh,
you know,
I no longer want to marry you and let her flip out and let us scream and yell
and say she's gonna kill herself and all that.
Dude,
you know,
you can feel bad for her,
but you know,
you live once,
okay?
You only live once.
Okay.
And being married is difficult.
Even when you marry the right person.
Forget about somebody that,
that's,
that emotionally the Radigan she's saying,
I wish I never got fucking married
so early in the marriage that you haven't even submitted the fucking papers.
I Made Jesus Christ.
Dude,
take the hint and you're not happy and you've already made the decision.
[inaudible] we know what you're worried about,
dude.
It's going to be weird for a bout fucking four or five days.
It's like shaving your head.
People like,
dude,
what the fuck?
And half to five days,
I can't remember what you look like with hair doodle.
Walk away walking dumper and just go to the bar and get yourself a really nice
fucking Ipa,
right?
A really nice fucking bear.
Whatever the fuck you want.
And just sit there and just know that you,
your whole future is,
is,
is just wide open,
wide open.
Anything can fucking happen.
Okay.
And that's it dude.
Walk the fuck away
and God bless you for writing in before you ended up in that other guy's
situation.
12 years in and you got that fucking nightmare.
Please start that startup.
Dude.
I'm not kidding.
I'll give you a fucking 500 bucks.
All right.
Worried about my future.
Uh,
hey Billy,
eight ball.
I love the comedy,
the podcasts,
all of it.
I have a problem and was wondering to get some of your advice.
I am the oldest of six and I am a junior and I am a junior in high school and
soon entering my senior year,
everything is going fine,
but the only thing is that I don't want to go to college.
Well then don't go.
I personally think college is a scam and unless you want to do to do specialized
profession,
unless you want to do a specialized profession,
I 100% agree.
But besides that,
it's nothing but an institution to make debt slaves.
All right,
well,
okay.
Okay,
relax,
relax.
It's also a great place to meet women.
You know,
it's a great,
it's a great social thing too.
Uh,
he goes,
I want to leave my home state and move out to Wyoming and become a correctional
officer.
Uh,
the only problem is my parents want me to become a lawyer.
I don't want to become a lawyer.
I want to be,
I want to do law enforcement.
I didn't think I should go about telling them I love the podcast and go fuck
yourself.
So I would say,
mom and dad,
I have something important that I need to talk to you about.
Don't worry,
nobody's pregnant.
I'm not on drugs.
Okay.
Start with that joke.
So they'll relax.
It's not life or death.
Just something I need to talk to you about.
Sit and down and say,
listen,
I don't want to be a lawyer.
I want to be in law enforcement.
And then that's it.
And let them react how they're going to react.
But you do what you want to do in life.
Uh,
I wouldn't have such a bleak look about how you're definitely informed,
but you don't want to get so dark that you bump people out that you say stuff
like dead slaves.
Um,
there's also people that go to college for one year and they meet somebody else
and then all of a sudden they build the computer and they make fucking billions
of dollars.
There's all different ways you can do it.
There's also ways go to a fucking community college for two years and then
transfer into the fucking more expensive,
fancier school.
The piece of paper's still going to say that you graduated from there,
you're going to cause going to cost you half as much.
There's a bunch of ways to do it.
All right.
Um,
but I would just sit down,
just
tell your parents what the deal is.
Just let him know.
Like I said,
that you didn't get anybody pregnant in union.
I'd fucking uh,
on drugs so they can fucking relax.
Sorry.
Boston or Chicago for a lady,
a Billy Burger.
Tits.
Um,
I'll have you know that I'm back into working out,
back doing pushups.
Um,
I don't have burger tits.
I have slider tits.
Thank you very much.
I'm a 28 year old engineer from the north shore there.
Went to school in Boston,
now work in Boston and I live in Somerville saying the rent they used to be
called Slummerville.
Now it's all fucking hipsters and cupcake places and all that.
It's amazing.
I started dating this girl a little over a year ago who lives in Somerville too,
but it's from Chicago
ball,
but is from Chicago.
She just got a new job in Chicago and is moving back there in a month.
We talked about this happening before and kind of just decided to play it by
beer,
she said and deal with it when it comes.
Well it came and short term solution is that I will stay in Boston for the next
year and do long distance relationship.
All right,
wait a second.
Start dating this new girl.
A little oversee.
Been in it for a year.
You're 28 okay,
so I guess my problem is that I'm kind of at an age where I should buy a house
instead of throwing money away on rent.
So if I decided to move to Chicago,
I think we would settle down there and stay there.
But I love living in the Boston area.
Granted,
I've never lived anywhere else,
so who knows what it will be like.
I'm still very close with all my high school friends who all live around here.
My old man's always on me about buying a house here and wants to fix it up
together.
If I moved to Chicago,
that doesn't help.
Do I choose the girl?
And life most likely in Chicago or stay here,
save up for a house,
be close to friends and family and try to convince her to come back to Boston.
Um,
so I,
a few years ago at the Wilbur,
we'll be at the garden show in October with the boys.
Can't fucking wait dude.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
Um,
I dunno dude,
is she the one?
Um,
that's what I would ask myself.
I would just do what I want.
I want you do this over the next fucking year.
Why don't you go out there and visit Chicago
and see if you like it and see if you still like that person.
The great thing is you don't have to make this decision right now.
And if you wait another year to buy a house,
no biggie.
Okay.
As far as making a rash,
fucking decision,
dumping this person or buying a place in Boston or,
or buying a place out there before you know about,
I would just go out there and I'd get the lay of the land.
I get the lay of the land there.
I can tell you
Chicago is,
uh,
an incredible city.
I love it.
The food's amazing.
The people are amazing.
The sports there are incredible,
but you know whose kid note you're always going to be a Celtics Bruins,
red sox or patriots fan that you just have to be.
But now you've got the sports packages and all of that.
But I can't tell you since 1995 I've been living behind enemy lines as a sports
fan.
I don't think it'll be as bad in Chicago.
Um,
I just live in New York and La,
so it was like fucking Yankee fans and Laker fans.
So it's just that bullshit.
Um,
also during the curse of the Bambino.
so,
but that is a big decision.
Um,
and I don't know how much you're into this person.
All right.
I would think of what your soul mate,
it would be a no brainer and you just go wherever the fuck she was going.
Within reason though,
cause you can meet your fucking soul mate.
You know,
if they go into some shit all,
you know,
you're not going to want that.
But Chicago was not a shit hole.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I obviously I can't make this decision for you,
but,
uh,
if you think,
I dunno,
you know,
when you know,
you know when you're with the right fucking person.
So if you feel that,
then I would,
you know,
worry about going somewhere where she lives.
Uh,
because it's Chicago.
I mean,
that's a good move.
Chicago's fucking great.
One thing went from Boston to like fucking,
I don't know Albany,
no offense Albany,
but you know what the fuck?
Um,
I don't know to what,
I can't make this fucking decision for you,
but I wouldn't buy a house or move out there until you figured it out.
How about that?
Uh,
your high school friends,
but you guys are all going to get married and have kids and then you're never
going to fucking see each other anyways.
I can tell you that.
Um,
or barely see each other or fucking go out and happy to be home by nine 30 or 10
o'clock for the sitter,
which is a really healthy life,
which is why I wished,
you know,
I got married and had kids along fucking time ago.
I wouldn't be fucking out there running around,
um,
staying out all hours of the night,
which is what I would do because I didn't want to go back to the empty lonely
hotel room.
So I would stay out as long as I could tell us about ready to fall asleep and I
would just coming to the hotel room and just fucking collapsed.
Uh,
so they go,
there's my advice from a fucking moron comedian.
All right.
That,
that was my,
my pinion as a male for me anyways.
All right.
Go Celtics game to a red sox and Yankees tied for first place,
which is fucking awesome.
A Red Sox is on fire now.
We've cooled off.
Now the Yankees are on fire tied for first place and maybe they're a game ahead.
It's right where you want it.
It's no fun being at first place if the Yankees aren't there as a red sox fan.
Okay.
And we've played each other's six times.
They were three and three so hopefully we'll get to,
you know,
battle it out in September.
Maybe we both make the make the playoffs and we meet once again in October.
That's what I'm hoping for.
And hopefully the Lakers get fucking good against so we can beat their asses in
the final next year.
God knows they'll go out and fucking uh,
get a whole bunch of free agents.
Who doesn't want to play out their racist La,
it's always summer and a,
you can fuck movie stars.
All right.
That's it as opposed to racist Boston where you got to deal with the witness and
for the most part you go walk around fucking sixes and sevens,
I guess you'd fuck tens but there's not as many tens in Boston.
Yeah.
And then in the end,
the best tense,
the top of the line 10.
So they all leave.
They all go to the majors like New York or fucking in La,
and then New York and La claim them as if they're from them,
but they're not like New York City is a free agent town as is la.
There's just a bunch of fucking people coming in there.
Um,
so anyways.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I will check in on you on Thursday.
Thanks for all the kind of notes about the bill Hader interview.
Uh,
I would like to do more of those in the future.
Um,
and that's it.
And if you haven't checked out Barry yet on Hbr,
promoted against a might be my favorite show out there right now.
All right,
that's it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.